i just really struggle with the
robustness and the generalizability of a
finding where even within this cohort
you know because the place that most
people go with this when they see this
headline is oh [ __ ]
i need to stop having diet soda and i
guess i'll switch to like regular
sugared beverages like maybe fruit juice
or maybe a full sugar soda whatever the
case may be but even within this cohort
artificially sweet artificial
artificially sweetened beverages were
not associated with cancer risk but
sugar sweetened beverages were and even
100 fruit juice was significantly
associated with cancer within this
cohort
and so uh
if the utility of this is to basically
find an alternative beverage for your uh
you know artificially sweetened beverage
uh it doesn't leave a lot on the table
really uh because if you're going for
fruit juice
if you're going for a full sugar
beverage based on this study it wouldn't
necessarily indicate that that's a
trade-off that would be indicated um
and i thought one other thing that kind
of
relates to that as i was going through
this i was thinking okay so
what exactly
is the alternative here because usually
when people talk about artificial
sweeteners it's about the trade-off
between having something that's
artificially sweetened versus something
that is sweetened with sugar or some
other kind of caloric sweetener like
honey or something like that
so
what they did here in this study was
they broke it down into like a grid with
six categories so it was like you're
either eating above the sugar
recommendation
or or you're below it so high sugar
intake or low
and then also you had no artificial
sweeteners
or low artificial sweetener intake or
high so you've got for artificial
sweeteners three categories none low or
high and then for sugar you're above the
recommendation or you're below
so
the hierarchy that they kind of set up
in one of the supplementary figures was
the best case scenario for cancer risk
based on the this cohort these findings
was low sugar intake and no artificial
sweeteners um
fair enough not very fun for your taste
buds uh then they've got this kind of
next best thing which was you know
slightly elevated in terms of cancer
risk again within this cohort
and it was you know if you had low sugar
intake and low artificial sweetener
intake if you had low sugar intake and
high artificial sweetener intake
or if you had high sugar intake and no
artificial sweetener intake all three of
those were pretty much equivalent in
terms of the cancer incidence that the
hazard ratio calculated the worst case
scenario was was two categories or two
kind of combinations of these categories
high sugar with low artificial sweetener
intake or high sugar
with high artificial sweetener intake so
it would seem for some reason
that the you know if we're assuming that
there you know really is a deleterious
impact here of artificial sweeteners it
seemed to be most pronounced in the
people who had high sugar intakes but
when you look at the people who had
really who were below the daily
recommendation for sugar
it really wasn't so bad you know is this
kind of middle of the road kind of pack
where there was all these different
combinations of sugar and artificial
sweeteners that
weren't as good as the
low sugar no sweetener group
but still it wasn't getting under those
really high elevations that were
observed in people who are eating a lot
of sugar in combination with a lot of
artificial sweeteners
the the low or the high artificial
sweetener group so
in a nutshell uh you might be looking at
these findings and being like man these
seem kind of contradictory kind of
counter-intuitive there doesn't seem to
be that clear of a dose-response
relationship
within the cohort it looks like the way
you define artificial sweetener intake
has a huge impact
like the source of the artificial
sweeteners has a big impact
overall i'm just not really convinced
that these are
these associations reported are truly
robust and generalizable and have a huge
impact on cancer risk so i personally i
look through this paper i don't find it
to be particularly concerning doesn't
mean the researchers did anything wrong
but that is kind of the nature of
nutritional epidemiology if if you put
all of your food related decisions into
a singular finding from nutritional
epidemiology you would have a very
confusing time trying to put together a
diet that had you know no potentially
deleterious uh
outcomes likely